i think generally speaking the media
believed they know better
and so they'll allow this democracy
thing this republic thing
to play out every so often but once
they've decided enough is enough
well enough is enough so neil cavuto
also on fox news committed an absolutely
unforgivable act the other day
kaylee mcenany the press secretary who
makes all of our hearts go pitter-patter
she was giving a press conference
describing
in detail what was going on the the many
irregularities
at these polling places and
i i almost can't even say it neil cavuto
cut away from kaylee
ten thousand swords should leap from
their scabbards to avenge even an
insulting glance
from a established media journalist much
less
cutting her off mid-sentence i was
furious take a listen
there is only one party in america
trying to keep
observers out of the count room and that
party my friends
is the democrat party you don't take
these positions because you want an
honest election
you don't oppose an audit of the vote
because you want an accurate count
you don't oppose our efforts at sunlight
and transparency because you have
nothing to hide
you take these positions because you are
welcoming fraud and you are welcoming
illegal voting
our position is clear we want to protect
the franchise of the american people
we want an honest accurate lawful count
we want maximum sunlight we want maximum
transparency we want every legal vote to
be counted
and we want every illegal vote well i
just think we have to be very clear
she's charging up the other side is
welcoming fraud and welcoming illegal
voting unless she has more details to
back that up
i can't in good countenance continue
showing you this i want to make sure
that maybe they do have something to
back that up
but that's an explosive charge to make
the other side is effectively
rigging and cheating it's an explosive
charge it's it's outrageous unless she's
got evidence to back that up
and i don't know what the evidence is
because i'm just a journalist so i i
obviously haven't looked into this at
all
well you know actually if any of the
journalists
would open their eyes and and if they
could stop uh
lavishing praise on joe biden for one
second and stop congratulating the
president-elect joe biden for just one
second
you'd see a lot of evidence a lot of
evidence of fraud and irregularities now
that doesn't mean that the the evidence
of fraud and irregularities
is enough to change the result of the
election we don't know
that's what the legal process is for but
to say that there is
no evidence whatsoever that is crazy
that is
simply ignorant ronna mcdaniel who is
the head of the rnc
and a michigan native she outlined just
a little bit of the evidence that they
found in michigan
poll watchers are pull election workers
blocked windows and padlock doors
obviously that's that's not going to
instill confidence um there are
thousands of reports of poll watchers
being intimidated and unable to do their
job
and as of 4 pm this afternoon 131
affidavits have been completed just in
michigan
with over 2800 incident reports that
have been submitted
to us since election day two new
lawsuits were filed today by people who
were working who were working
in detroit and a whistleblower who has
gotten their informat we have gotten
their information to the eastern
district court of michigan
as you guys can understand with 2800
incident reports
this is a lot to track down it means
we're interviewing these people we're
getting their statements and we're
turning them into affidavits
in addition to that we've heard hundreds
of instances of election workers who
were verbally accosted
are pulled they verbally accosted our
poll watchers and refusals to let them
challenge questionable ballots election
workers were wearing biden t-shirts
and applauding when our poll watchers
were kicked out
2 800 incident reports 100 what was it
she said 130 some odd
affidavits already sworn affidavits
we already knew i guess uh neil and some
of the other
establishment journalists didn't know
that republican poll watchers
were not permitted to watch the polls
and then at least in philadelphia
there's a court order saying you have to
let them watch
you know what you know what happened
they still were not permitted to watch
the polls
what's that about i hope you enjoyed
that short segment from the michael
knowles show be sure to check out the
full episode linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you